l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 425 de Monsieur André
Richardt monsieur le ministre du Travail
de l'Emploi de la Formation
Professionnelle et du dialogue social
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre les chiffres du chômage au
niveau national au mois de mars dernier
sont à nouveau mauvais plus
36900 chômeurs soit une augmentation de
1,2%. nous arrivons aujourd'hui à une
augmentation de 11,5% sur un an sur un
taux de chômage de
10,6% en France en Alsace la situation
n'est pas meilleure loin sans faux dans
notre région monsieur le ministre qui
avait il y a peu vous le savez
certainement le plus faible taux de
chômage de France nous comptons
aujourd'hui
90 900 chômeurs soient près du double du
double de la fin des années 90 en un an
la hausse du chômage y a été de 12,6%
soit plus d'un point de plus que le
pourcentage national que je citais tout
à l'heure les seniors et les jeunes sont
les catégories les plus touchées ces
fréquents les plus de 50 ans ont vu leur
taux de chômage grimper de deux et demi
pour cent le mois dernier du 18,6% en un
an du coup le nombre de bénéficiaires du
RSA s'accroît aujourd'hui en Alsace près
d'un chômeur sur 5 touches le revenu de
solidarité active 1 sur 5 la situation
ne semble pas prête à s'améliorer
puisque les offres collectées par Pôle
emploi dans la région ont encore une
fois chuté sur les trois derniers mois
et c'est le Haut-Rhin notamment qui est
plus particulièrement touché lui qui est
frappé de plein fouet par la
désindustrialisation avec une nouvelle
vague de suppression de poste et de
restructuration dans la région
colmarienne particulièrement l'emploi
industriel y est particulièrement à la
peine surtout dans les grosses
structures mais elle est TPE comme on
dit en Alsace comme au niveau national
ne sont pas très bien l'outil non plus
leur croissance a été quasi nul en 2012
et près de la moitié ont enregistré une
baisse de leur vente
7% des TPE prévoit de recruter cette
année la principale difficulté est
recensée naturellement pas un scoop
concerne la compétitivité insuffisante
de nos entreprises votre gouvernement
monsieur le ministre a mis en place
diverses initiatives qui a pour but de
permettre à celle-ci de retrouver la
compétitivité souhaitée force est
malheureusement de constater que
celle-ci ne permet pas de renverser la
tendance à titre particulier dans le
secteur du bâtiment les mesures
annoncées par le président facteur en
faveur du logement social et de la
rénovation énergétique sont
insuffisantes et ne produisent pas les
lents nécessaires dans ce domaine je
souhaite évoquer deux leviers essentiels
à la reprise d'activité d'une part la
TVA 5,5 pour la rénovation des logements
et d'autre parce que la CAPEB appelle la
lutte pour la moralisation de la vie
économique au travers de
l'assainissement du régime des
auto-entrepreneurs votre gouvernement a
encore toute possibilité monsieur le
ministre d'appliquer au 1er janvier 2014
la TVA 5 sur la rénovation des et pas
uniquement sur les travaux d'économie
d'énergie faites-le je souhaite
également attirer votre attention sur la
diminution majeure de la production de
prêt bancaire à titre d'exemple d'après
des données fournies par une grande
banque alsacienne par rapport à mars
2012 les cris à la consommation chuter
11,9% en un an et les crédits
immobiliers 22% cette baisse
significative est inquiétante face à
tout cela pouvez-vous me dire monsieur
le ministre quelle nouvelle mesure vous
pouvez vous compter mettre en oeuvre et
le plus rapidement possible pour
indiquer le fléau que constitue le
chômage merci
merci mon cher collègue monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur le tableau très sombre que vous
avez dressé correspond malheureusement à
l'exact réalité pour la nation comme
pour votre département et votre région
cet état de fait est le résultat d'une
dégradation vous l'avez dit la
compétitivité française qui est ancienne
et continue qui nous a conduit un
commerce extérieur que vous savez
éminemment déficitaire à une
augmentation du chômage un million dans
les 5 années qui viennent de se passer
la continuation à la dégradation en même
temps de nos comptes publics bref des
indicateurs en tout point inquiétant qui
durent depuis des années en effet le
gouvernement a décidé cela pourrait-il
lui coûter un instant une certaine forme
bien entendu de popularité de prendre
très sérieusement en compte ces
différents éléments structurels
difficiles par la maîtrise des déficits
publics par la mise en oeuvre d'un accès
aux crédit avec la banque publique
d'investissement vous l'avez évoqué
vous-même par la mise en place de
mesures qui n'ont pas encore produit
c'est vrai leur plein effet je pense au
contrat de génération je pense aux
emplois d'A en s'attaquant donc un
certain nombre de réformes structurelles
et en particulier le fameux coup du
travail il faut appeler les choses
telles qu'elles sont facteurs clés de la
compétitivité car c'est bien sûr
gouvernement qui a suivi les
recommandations du rapport Gallois on
peut toujours trouver c'est le cas du
président de la République c'est le
vôtre que les choses ne vont pas assez
vite mais ces dispositifs sont
maintenant actés comme la réforme du
marché du travail qui est sans doute
donne plus de sécurité mais aussi plus
de flexibilité aux entreprises pour que
l'emploi des salariés ne soit pas en
permanence la variable d'ajustement et
que dans la période très difficile que
nous traversons les entreprises puissent
s'adapter vous savez que toutes ces
mesures ont été prises en peu de temps
d'autres sont annoncés puisque vous le
demandez je pense par exemple à la
réforme de la formation professionnelle
qui est tellement insatisfaisante au
moyen 2000 emplois que le premier
ministre vient de donner en plus pour
que Pôle Emploi puisse accompagner nos
demandeurs d'emploi dans la recherche
recherche d'un travail et dans la
formation et la qualification toutes ces
mesures doivent concourir à la reprise
elles doivent faciliter le travail des
entreprises améliorer leur compétitivité
mieux former nos salariés sans que nous
ayons dégradé en rien les mécanismes
vous le savez et même au contraire pour
le RSA les mécanismes d'assistance pour
ceux qui malheureusement sont touchés
par ces éléments très difficiles
maintenant cette action doit se
poursuivre dans la durée elle aura si
nécessaire le président de la République
l'a dit à s'accentuer car il y a là pour
nous tous un défi considérable c'est il
y a plus de 20 ans qu'une
communication avait été faite sur la
préférence française pour le chômage
nous n'avons pas démenti et combien de
faibles croissants ces dernières années
avec de la croissance à taux zéro nous
n'avons malheureusement pas démenti à
travers les alternances cette préférence
le temps est venu c'est ce que nous
appelons le redressement de la France
nous avons besoin de toutes les énergies
pour le conduire
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur
Richard
c'est le ministre je ne vous surprendrai
pas en vous disant que votre réponse ne
me satisfait pas
vous me citez la boîte à outils pour
reprendre l'expression du président de
la République malheureusement je connais
cette boîte à outils
vous l'avez reconnu vous-même le moins
que l'on puisse dire c'est qu'elle ne
produit pas c'est
ses effets
pour une raison à mon sens majeur c'est
qu'elle est faite pour accompagner une
croissance et non pas pour la susciter
et ce dont nous avons besoin c'est
vraiment de mesures suscitant cette
croissance en Alsace particulièrement
Monsieur le Ministre et je vous remercie
de l'avoir prise en compte nous sommes
en compétition économique avec des
régions économiquement énormes et très
forte je vise le bas du retomberg je
vise les cantons du Nord-Ouest de la
Suisse c'est vraiment ce sont vraiment
des locomotives respectivement de
l'Allemagne et de la Suisse et dans ces
conditions là chaque jour qui passe est
un jour perdu pour la compétitivité de
nos entreprises je peux vous le garantir
l'assuré je voudrais vous dire aussi que
le crédit impot compétitivité ne
profitant pas à cette masse de petite
entreprise individuelle puisque
naturellement pour pouvoir en bénéficier
il faut payer des salaires ce que les
entreprises individuelles ne font pas
c'est pour l'Alsace qui a un tissu très
développé de ce qu'on appelle c'est ctpe
c'est une vraie catastrophe parce que
celle-ci sont vraiment dépourvues je
voudrais monsieur le mix je vous assure
en dehors de toute polémique vraiment
vous priez de bien vouloir relayer au
plus haut niveau ces inquiétudes
alsaciennes je le répète nous ne sommes
pas une région comme une autre nous
sommes en compétition avec des
entreprises qui de l'autre côté la mine
la compétition à l'heure actuelle et
pour nous c'est une c'est vrai
véritablement une situation dramatique
que celle que nous vivons à l'heure
actuelle je voudrais que vous en preniez
conscience
merci mon cher collègue